5 55 on your monday morning well the
nevada department of transportation
wants you to
sign in may remember back in august ndot
announced a contest for short snappy
messages that could end up on some or
all of the state's
400 or so overhead size well they've
narrowed the field of potential winners
down to 11 and now indot wants you to
vote for your top three
from these entries when driving use your
thinker
and your blinker that's the temperature
not the speed texts means
wrecks it's not a race leave some space
there's no need to drive at warp speed
practice vehicle social distancing don't
tailgate your seat belt looks good on
you
gamble at the casino not your car buckle
up camp in the mountains
not the left lane turn signals come free
with vehicles use them don't get
exhausted
tailgating blows all right only one
entry per person you have to be 16 to
vote you've got until june 15th to vote
at dot.nv.gov sign so that link and all
the entries there in the online version
of this story at 8newsnow.com
when you click traffic then driving you
crazy buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me traffic eight
at now dot com